mental health for our youth it is a
major concern it certainly is a recent
study from the National Council for
mental well-being shows that there are
service gaps all across the country we
certainly know that sitting here Candace
Charles joining us now from Roseman
University in Henderson with a look at
the opening of a vital community
resource Candace
good morning into good morning folks
we've worked with Adam's Place before
we're excited that they're opening two
new locations one here in Henderson on
the Roseman University campus as well as
one in Summerlin now I'm joined with
Kelly Boyer the executive director we
want to give you guys a little bit of a
walk through with this office is going
to be providing as well as some of the
things I already have here so tell us
what's in this office and this is really
our training Hub we work with volunteers
across the community to come in to be
volunteer facilitators in various
activities we run with the youth so we
have a mock room for training we use
additional space
families come here when they first are
registering for Camp cope and then we
have our other group rooms on campus so
we're excited about being at Summerlin
Medical Center that's a hub for us as
well and here in Henderson all right
photography and we know a lot about Camp
cope we've talked to you guys about the
program before and we know that you're
now in schools as well in helping some
of the counselors how is that work going
what are you guys seeing it's amazing
because we know we'll reach thousands of
kids that way but getting the materials
to the professionals that are in the
schools and they can run groups in real
time it takes away Transportation as a
barrier for kids to come to our program
so together the partnership allows
groups to be held in school sites and
then we also have our camp Co program
that they can refer families to on an
ongoing basis and then we have Community
engagement activities throughout the
year that all kids from across the Clark
County can come to perfect and I know
really quickly you have some resources
and ideas for people to use at home as
well as you have a little bit of an
opportunity for folks as well yes we do
and skills at home if you go to our
website adamsonlv.org we have book
reviews that's the number one two and
there's ideas about how to talk with
your children journaling on
communicating through writing in case
there's not the conversation that you
can start
and then listening and listening to your
child and making that consistent to
check in with them we do have your
opportunities coming up we are putting
the call out because we're so excited to
be able to see kids again in person next
week to boot camp go to our website
register as a volunteer perfect Kelly
thank you so much for chatting with us
always great to see you and thank you so
much for the work you're doing it really
is needed right now I really appreciate
it okay they'll be opening up here today
at Forever they'll be doing a ribbon
cutting and they'll be doing a ribbon
cutting over in Summerlin at 10 30. you
can find out more details on our website
8newsnow.com for now live in here Cinema
Candace Charles 8 News Now